- So it was revealed in "Keeping
up with the Kardashians"
that Kim Kardashian did not in
fact pass the baby bar exam.
I covered this story two years ago.
Kim Kardashian is trying to
become a lawyer in California
through a little-used
apprenticeship program.
She's not going to an
accredited law school,
she's trying to become a lawyer
by being an apprentice for other lawyers.
And, as part of that process,
you have to take the baby bar exam.
This is a thing in California where,
if you don't go to an
accredited law school
or you're using this apprenticeship thing,
you have to take a test to make sure
that you are up to snuff
so that you can continue
and not waste everyone's time and money.
She came relatively close,
but didn't actually pass,
and I applaud her for
putting in the hard work.
It would be really easy
for a celebrity like her
to just completely phone it in.
It seems like she's being genuine
and I imagine she could do a lot of good
for criminal justice reform
if she were able to pass the bar.
So I'm rooting for Kim to
take the baby bar exam again
and continue in her studies.